показали отой документ на основі якого
було зупинено фінансування нашої
ракетної програми Грімм де підписи людей
засвідчили про те що це не перспективно
не потрібно і треба зупинити це ж
конкретні люди вони поставили свої
підписи обґрунтувавши що нам не потрібно
фінансувати ракети середньої дальності
це має бути відповідальність не завтра
не післязавтра уже Сьогодні якщо не
вчора або Якщо говорити про сьогоднішній
день от вчорашня чи позавчорашня заява в
Кабінету Міністрів про те що ми виділили
40 мільярдів гривень на програму Дронів
слухайте аби чим займалися до цього часу
ви що думаєте що ви сьогодні виділили 40
мільярдів
дрони почнуть літати Ну за це теж Хтось
має відповісти Ну ця суцільна
непрофесійність помножена на роботу
московських кротів які поверталися в
українські органи влади